ah yes
that's why these comedians are [__]
too dude like this whole [__] uh uh
uh
uh the the the the the
like Bobby and kalila breaking up let
them break up
everyone's in the comments like oh you
don't know how good he has it she has it
this happened and really she's
controlling and that happened and and
and and and he did this and I feel bad
for her and ah shut up dude
that's annoying as [__] for me could you
imagine what it's like for them dude
and then people are hitting me up you
should comment on this
dude I ain't no [__] dude I'm no [__]
with that
people want me to talk about what
happened with this person that person
that person this person that I know
personally dude eat my shorts man
that's some [__] [__] man I'm gonna
talk about my opinions on whatever
someone else is going on personally that
I know personally I'm gonna give the and
um you want some drama from me that's
[__] [__] dude that's what comedians
are doing right now with the gossip no
dude that's that's not me man I'm Bill
Daffy
I'll get Clicks in other ways man
I get Clicks in other way I am not
commenting on a [__] that did
some [__] outside of the comedy store or
whatever bro you think I can on unload
the clip now
All Rise different dude [__] that Joan
River [__] rest in peace she was great
but that [__] that people do for clicks
that is [__] [__] no I will not do it
and I sometimes I think maybe I should
[__] you know maybe I should maybe I
should just
give up and just unload the clip but man
it ain't right first of all it's not
recovery based second of all it's just
not the that's not the kind of [__] I
want to do that's not the kind of
comedian I want to do I make fun of
people I don't know
and I don't mean it
that's it to me that's what being a
comedy comedian is all about because
this [__] this podcast game where oh
what happened with this and that I can't
man
I can't I won't I can't I can't actually
do that and then like look at my dad and
mom who I know raised me and and think
that everything's gonna be all good
because they didn't raise me to be that
way
my dad was the [__] like that though my
dad was the [__] my dad was just like
you know
you got to be honest with me 100 all the
time I always got your back no matter
what there I said it and that's that and
he meant it dude
he meant it
and that's beautiful
uh and I mean it too dude like there's
your family that you have and then
there's your friends that and I don't
mean to sound so [__] Persian right
now but it's seriously hey there's your
family that you have and then you don't
get to choose them and then you have
friends that are your family because you
choose them and that's more important in
a way but I'm you know man that's like
Burn It Down
Let It Burn
like imagine like remember when Usher
had the thing about the herpes
and like yeah I don't know if that's
true or not it's probably not but then
like no nobody like that this is what
comedians do like comedians will just
talk about that [__] like God forbid
like [__] what's his name uh somebody
anybody John Mulaney had herpes comedy
community boom we did talk about it
there'd be people on podcast oh so you
hear the latest news dude eat my shorts
dude eat my shorts man
like that's that that's like if it's
[__] Usher did the herpes thing and
then all of a sudden you got uh what's
his name uh
tank the R B singer singing about how
ushers got herpes like dude
you all up in people's business for
clicks or sales that I can't tell you
how much that's [__] [__] and I you
know that's not bad about it dude and
one thing about me is I'm bad about it
[Music]
congratulations